اشتباكات تتخلل بدا سريان الهدنه
الانسانيه في السودان
وبعد تبادل الاتهامات بخرقها مصادر بالجيش
السوداني وبالدعم السريع تؤكد للجزيره
الالتزام بتطبيق الهدنه والسماحه بعوده
الحياه لطبيعتها وقبل سريان الهدنه معارك
السيطره على مواقع استراتيجيه في الخرطوم
ومروي ولبيض تتصاعد وتقارير متضاربه حول
مال المواجهات
بعد خروج مستشفيات ومرافق صحيه عن الخدمه
بالسودان نظر كارثه انسانيه تتزايد منظمه
الصحه العالميه تحذر الامدادات الطبيه في
طريقها للنفاذ الصليب الاحمر الدولي يدق
ناقوس الخطر بعد انقطاع الكهرباء ونقص
المياه وتعطل المرافق وغضب اممي بنت
تقارير عن عرقله العمليات الانسانيه في
السودان واستهداف فرق اغاثه
وسط اتصالات الدبلوماسيه مكثفه بعد
محادثات هاتفيه لبلينكن مع البرهان وحميتي
البيت الابيض يحذر الطرفي الصراع من هجمات
او تهديدات على الدبلوماسيين الامريكيين
ومجموعه الدول السبع الكبرى تطالب طرفي
النزاع في السودان بالعوده الى طاوله
المفاوضات والامم المتحده تقول ان ممثله
في السودان يوصل اتصالاته للتامين وقف
فوري للتصعيد
السلام عليكم وصل معكم هذه التغطيه لما
يجري في السودان وبعد دخول الهدنه حيز
التنفيذ افاد مرسل الجزيره بتجدد
الاشتباكات وبتحليق طائرات حربيه جنوب
الخرطوم بينما ردت مضادات ارضيه بكثافه
وقالت قوات الدعم السريعه انها رصدت هجوما
على قواتها في القياده العامه الجريف شرق
معبد الهدنه وقال المتحدث باسم الامين
العام للامم المتحده ان القتال مستمر وانه
لم يكن هناك وقف حقيقي للمعارك كما دعا
الى وقف الاعتداءات على العاملين في
المجال الانساني
وكان طرف القتال قد وافق على مقترح امريكي
بشان هدنه لضمان المرور الامن للمدنيين
واجلاء الجرحى وقالت مصادره برئاسه مجلس
السياده السوداني للجزيره ان رئيس المجلس
عبد الفتاح البرهان وافق على هدنه لمده 24
ساعه بدلا من السادسه من مساء اليوم وذلك
استجابه لنداءات دوريه
في المقابل اعلنت قواته الدعم السريع
موافقتها على الهدنه وفي بيان عبر تويتر
قالت قوات الدعم السريع ان قصف المدنيين
يعد انتهاكا صارخا لاسس ومبادئ القانون
الانساني الدولي كما اتهمت القوات المسلحه
السودانيه بعدم احترام قرار وقف اطلاق
النار وبقصف مناطق سكنيه
وكان الجيش السوداني قد دعى المجتمع
الدولي الى الضغط ضد الجرائم الانسانيه
التي يرتكبها دقلو وقواته وفق تعبيره في
اشاره الى قائد الدعم السريع واتهم بيان
الجيش قوات الدعم السريع باقتحام بيوت
المدنيين ونشرق قناصه داخلها وعلى اسطحها
سيكون معنا شبكه مراسلين لكن نبدا باسامه
سيدي احمد مراسل الجزيره من مروي شمال
السودان واصداء الهدنه لديك واخر الانباء
عن مواقع كل من الدعم السريع وايضا قوات
الجيش هو موقف مطار مروي
يعني زين اذا تحدثنا عن مفهوم الهدنه التي
تم اعلانها اخيرا هنا الناس ما كانوا
ينتظرون هذه الهدنه بل بدات قبل هذه
الهدنه الاخيره لان يعني صمتت البنادق ولم
يعد هناك صوت لاي معركه ما عدا الطلعات
الجويه التي قامت بها
الطائره الحربيه التي قصفت عده عده اهداف
بالنسبه لقوات الدعم السريع التي كانت
تنتشر في عده يعني مناطق في منطقه مروي
هذه المعطيات الميدانيه ربما بدات في منذ
امس ليله امس وصبيحه هذا اليوم
وكانت يعني
هناك هناك بالنسبه
للسيارات القوات سريع كانت لها تاثيرات
عميقه بحسب بحسب مصادر اكدت لنا ان هناك
اكثر من خمسين سياره تابعه لقوات الدعم
السريعه تم تدميرها بشكل كامل هذه ربما
معطيات تشير الى ان بحسب مصادر الجيش قالت
ان هذه الطلعات الجويه التي قامت بها قام
بها سلاح الجو
التابع للجيش السوداني ذكر بان تم اجبار
القوات التي كانت ترتكز في محيط مطر مروي
وداخل مطار مروي بالخروج والانسحاب ليس
كان يعني حينما وصلت هذه القوات بارتال
كبيره بحسب شهود عيان الى منطقه الملتقى
التي تبعد نحو 100كم تقريبا جنوب محيط
مطار مروي هذه
المعطيات اشارت الى ان هذا هو الانسحاب
الذي قصده
الجيش ولكن هذه السيارات حينما تحرك تحرك
جديد من هذه المنطقه واجهه نيران الطائره
الحربيه التي كانت تتعقب هذه القوات
المنسحبه واطلقت عليها نيران ثم بعد ذلك
يعني اكدت لنا بعض المصادر المحليه ان
هناك اعداد من السيارات التابعه للدعم
السريع وهذا الدعم السريع في بعض المناطق
داخل
محليه مروي خاصه في منطقه تنغاسي والغرير
هناك بحسب شهود عيان اكدوا ان هناك اعداد
من السيارات المدججه وعلامتها جنود
يرتكزون في عده مناطق في هذه في هذه
المحليه هذا يعني ان الانسحاب ربما لم يكن
كاملا هذا ما اكلته قوات نفسها حينما
اعلنت عن وجود هذه القوات في عدد من
المناطق داخل محليه
مروي ولم تنفذ انسحابا كاملا هذا ربما
يعطي اشاره زين
ربما يعني ربما
ضبابيه وربما يعني تشير الى ان وجود هذه
القوات في هذه المناطق ان هناك شيء ما
ربما قد يحدث والجيش السوداني قال انه مصر
لانهاء ما سماه التمرد في منطقه مروي
ويشون قال انه سيشون حمى حمراء حربا ينهي
بها وجود هذه القوات في هذه المنطقه
هذه اللحظه هادئه جدا الوضع ربما عاد الى
طبيعته ولم تكن هناك اي اشتباكات بين
الطرفين حتى هذه اللحظه يعني تقصد بطبيعته
ان الناس بداوا يخرجون ويمارسون حياتهم
الطبيعيه في مروي
نعم اقصد اقصد ذلك يعني هناك
ليست الوضع ليس في طبيعته ولكن هناك مخاوف
ولكن بدا الناس يعيشون حياتهم الطبيعيه
طالما ان البنادق الصمت طيله هذه الساعات
هل شاهدنا ذلك ايضا في الخرطوم نسال هيثم
اويت مراسل الجزيره من الخرطوم ونحن نتابع
معك ساعه بساعه اصداء هذه الهدنه التي
دخلت حيز التنفيذ في السادسه مساء يعني مر
عليها ساعات ما الذي تغير في الساعه
الماضيه
زينه لم يتغير الكثير حاله من الهدوء تسود
وسط الخرطوم ولكن ما زلنا نسمع دوي
انفجارات قويه او دانات لقذائف ربما من
اماكن بعيده حتى الان لا نستطيع ان نحدد
مواقعها ولكن من قوه هذه
القذائف او الانفجارات هي يعني يبدو انها
اما لاسلحه ثقيله او او لطائرات
ولكن ايضا هناك انباع اشتباكات في شرق
النيل هذه المنطقه ايضا ما زالت تشهد
اشتباكات مسلحه
وهذا هو حال الهدنه يبدو ان الهدنه حتى
الان لم تطبق بالشكل الكامل او المرجو
منها ولكن مع ذلك يعني تسود حاله من
الهدوء منطقه وسط الخرطوم حتى الان لم
يطرا عليها جديد لم نشهد حركه سيارات مثلا
عاديه او حركه مواطنين يتحركون داخل هذه
المنطقه وهي المنطقه التي شهدت يعني
اشتباكات بشكل عنيف وكبير خلال الايام
الاربعه الماضيه يجري القول زين ان يعني
هذه الاشتباكات او هذه الهدنه
المناطق التي يعني يستفاد منها اكثر هي
منطقه وسط الخرطوم وايضا الجسور التي كانت
مغلقه خلال الايام الماضيه هناك يعني
اناسون في سواء كان في الخرطبه او من
درمان او بحري كل يود ان يذهب الى الجانب
الاخر
يترقبون هذه الهدنه طبعا للعبور من والى
الجانب الاخر ولكن يعني حتى الان ما
رصدناه خلال الساعات الاولى لهذه الهدنه
صعوبه في في الحركه لم تنسب بالشكل
الطبيعي المنتظر هذا جانب الجانب الاخر
ايضا كان يعول من هذه الهدنه ان تساهم في
ايصال المساعدات الانسانيه
للمستشفيات والمرضى ولذوي الاحتياجات
الخاصه هم بحاجه الى رعايه صحيه وايضا
للمحتجزين داخل منطقه النطاق العمليات او
الاشتباكات التي كانت دائره في وسط
الخرطوبه وفي المناطق المتاخمه للقياده
العامه للقصر الجمهوري وللمطار والاحياء
القريبه من هذه المناطق التي
تقطعت السبل باناس في داخل هذه المناطق
ومنهم من يفقدون الان المؤن والغذاء
والدواء وحتى الماء المناطق الان تعيش
حاله من العطشه العديد من المناطق في
احياء سواء كان البحريه او في الخرطوم او
بعض الاحياء التي تاثرت جراء هذه
الاشتباكات التي ادت الى تاثر القطاعات
حيويه النتيجه لاصابتها ايضا بعض
المستشفيات يعني تستغيث الان هناك بحسب
لجنه الاطباء الان المستشفيات عديده خرجت
من الخدمه اكثر من 9 مستشفيات
باتت الان خارج الخدمه ولكن قالت اللجنه
الاطباء ان هناك سته مستشفيات يعني يمكن
ان توفر خدمات لغسيل الكلى في كل من مدن
الخرطوم درمان وبحري نعل ان هذه الشريحه
الان هي اكثر شريحه عرضه
للخطر توقف مراكز غسيل الكلى نسبه لهذه
الاشتباكات الدائره وان هناك مراكز كانت
تجاور مواقع القياده العامه التي ادارت
فيها الاشتباكات عموما ما زالت الاعمال
معقوده على ان تترجم هذه الهدنه الى واقع
في في الغد ربما باقي ساعه الليل وهو غدا
لتسهم في المساهمه في يعني تخفيف وطاه
الوضع الانساني المتفاقم جراء هذه
الاشتباكات زين لكن نقطه مهمه باشرت اليه
هيثم انه انسانيا هذه الهدنه انسانيه لكن
انسانيا لم يتغير الوضع الانساني نسال
الطائر المرضى ايضا في جنوب الخرطوم بعيدا
عن مناطق الاشتباك
كيف هي الامور في بقيه مناطق الخرطوم
ولا ثيمه مع انباء عن نشاط بعض العصابات
عصابات الجرائم
نعم اسمع بعض
الطلقات والانفجارات المتقطعه
الان قبل قليل
هذه يعني ان
الهدوء وهذه الهدنه هدوء حذر
شاهدت ايضا عدد من المواطنين في التحرك
لقضاء بعض اغراضهم لكنهم بشكل حذر جدا
ومحدود
هم ايضا عندما يسمعون هذه الطلقات يبدو في
التشكيك ان هذه الهدنه قد طبقت بشكل كامل
ام هنالك يعني ما قالت عنه الاطراف نفسها
لا يلغي او لا تلغي هذه الهدنه حق الرد
عندما تجاوز اي طرف هذه
من الناحيه من الناحيه الثانيه هذه الهدنه
تبدو انها لن تكون كافيه باعتبار ان مضى
منها وقت طويل ولم يستطيع الجهات المعنيه
على الوجه الاكمل بسبب التشكيك في ان تكون
هذه الهدنه كامله ويمكن التحرك دون ان
يتعرض السؤال كان المواطن او فرق الانقاذ
او حتى السيارات الاسعاف والذين يودون
التعامل مع هذه الظروف والاوضاع الانسانيه
بشكل كبير كذلك هنالك بيان للجيش السوداني
يتحدث عن ان في هنالك بعض المواقع لا تزال
تظهر فيها بعض
المناوشات من حين الى اخر هو ان هنالك
مستشفى قصف بسبب هذه
المناوشادو او بهذا السبب هذه المواجهات
وادت الى يعني اضرار كبيره في هذا
المستشفى في وسط الخرطوم وهو مختص
بالمرضى الذين يجودون في العنايه المكثفه
وفي قسم الطوارئ ادى الى نقصان في الغاز
والوقود وكذلك
الرعب في اوساط الكادر الطبيه مما جعلهم
يتعاملون مع الوضع بشكل حذر ولا يتمكنون
من اداء دورهم بشكل جيد الامل ايضا في ان
تكون فتره الفتره الصباح فتره هودن حقيقيه
بحيث اني تستطيع المواطن ان يتحرك ويقوم
بقضاء حاجاته افراضه سواء كانت في الاسواق
المغلقه عندما تمكنت هذه الاسواق من فتح
ابوابها غدا وكذلك في مواقع
السفر في بعض هنالك شاهدنا برضو ملامح
رغبه عدد من كبير من المواطنين يودون
السفر خارجي الخرطوم كذلك نرى كيف يمكن
لهذه الهدنه ان تساعدهم في هذا الامر كما
ان هذه الهدنه ليست هناك معلومات كافيه هل
هي هدنه فقط لمده 24 ساعه
وامس ستجدد تلقائيا هذا ما لم تتحدث عنه
الاطراف حتى لم تذكره لنا كذلك المعلومات
الوارده من الجهات التي توصلت في هذا
الاطار كذلك لم ترد لنا اي اخبار عن الدور
الذي يمكن ان يقوم به الاتحاد الافريقي
بعد ان ذكر انه يريد الوصول الى الخرطوم
لم تتجدد تلك التصريحات في هذا الاطار
ولكن الذي تجدده هو ان القوه السياسيه
بمختلف انتماءاتها اصدرت بيانا وقالت لها
تريد ان ان توقف هذه الازمه بشكل جدي
وسريع واصدرت ايضا نداءات للمجتمع
الاقليمي والدولي لا تريد ان تدور هذه
القضيه تريد ان توقف الحرب وتوقف هذه
القتال وان تكون قضيه سودانيه داخليه تحل
داخل البيت السوداني الى اي مدى يجد هذا
النداء هذا يعني طريقه للتنفيذ اذا كانت
هنالك ترتيبات في هذا الاطار ولكن الوضع
الانساني بصفه عامه يشير لاتفاقمه بعد
دخول هذه الازمه يومها الخامس وان هنالك
احتياجات كثيره بالنسبه للمواطنين في هذا
الاطار لنرى كيف يمكن ان تكون الساعات
الاولى من الصباح او الصباح الغد كيف يتم
التعامل مع هذه المساله بشكل او باخر
شكرا لك من جنوب الخرطوم الطاهر المرضي
وشكرا لاسامه السيد احمد من مروي وايضا
هيثموي من الخرطوم
قال المتحدث باسمي غرفه عمليه الجيش
السوداني للعقيد خالد العقيده للجزيره ان
الجيش حريص على استمرار الهدنه وعلى عوده
الحياه الطبيعيه
لا تعرف
ها يعني
يكون رئيسا
وكل هذه التي هي امامكم هي خسائر بسبب
طموح شخص يريد ان يكون رئيسا
يا ربي ان يقول رئيسا
وفي المقابل قال موسى خدام مستشار قائد
قوات الدعم السريع للجزيره ان قواتهم
المنتشره في مختلف مناطق الخرطوم ملتزمه
بالهن
دعم الطريق هي الان مسيطره على كل ولايات
ولايه الخرطوم المجاوره
استخدام كبير جدا بالهدنه التي نوافر
عليها قائدها القائد محمد الحداد ولكن
انتم ترونوا الكاميرات لا تكذب الطائرات
منذ الصباح وفي نهار هذا اليوم وفي
كل المواقع وتروي على المواطنين داخل
مدينه الخرطوم
ومع دخول المواجهات المسلحه في السودان
يومها الرابع لم يحقق اي من الطرفين اي
اختراق على الارض الاشتباكات لا تزال
مستمره للسيطره على المواقع ذاتيه التي
شهدت اشتباكات في اليوم الاول وسط تبادل
الاتهامات بالماسونيه عن التجاوزات
الحقوقيه وانتهاك حقوق المدنيين والاجانب
لم يختلف اليوم الرابع من المواجهات
المسلحه في السودان عن الايام الثلاثه
التي سبقته الا بانتهائه بهدنه هشه سرعان
ما خلقت وكغيرها من احداث السودان خلال
الايام الماضيه تضاربت بشانها الاخبار
والمواقف والاتهامات وقبل اعلان الهدنه
هيمنه الاشتباكات على ساعات اليوم خصوصا
قرب القصر الجمهوري ومقر قياده الجيش
السوداني في العاصمه الخرطوم ونقل مراسل
الجزيره ان طائرات حلقت في اجواء العاصمه
واكد مصدر حكومي للجزيره ان قوات الدعم
السريع الموجوده في الجزء الغربي من حي
المطار في الخرطوم تعرضت لقصف المكثف من
الجيش خاصه في محيط مقر اقامه قائد الدعم
السريع محمد حمدان حميدتي ونشرت قوات
الدعم السريع مقطع فيديو يظهر وجود
عناصرها في محيط مطار الخرطوم الدولي
واظهر الفيديو وجود القوات امام الصاله
الرئاسيه وقت اشتعال النيران في احدى
الطائرات ويسمع في الفيديو اصوات اشتباكات
وانفجارات
شمالا وفي مروي حيث بدات شراره الاحداث
الاخيره تحتدم معارك وتتضارب الروايات
بشان السيطره على مطار المدينه وما يحمل
من اهميه امنيه واستراتيجيه فبعد اعلان
الجيش السيطره عليه وهروب قوه الدعم
السريع بعد محاولتها تدمير بنيته التحتيه
خرجت قوات الدعم السريع لتؤكد ان عناصرها
ما تزال متمركزه في محيطه اما مطار الابيض
الواقع على بعد 450 كيلومترا غرب الخرطوم
فالاشتباكات العنيفه في محيطه ما تزال
مستمرا ويعد هذا المطار مركزا لقوات الامم
المتحده لحفظ السلام في ابييه اما في
المواقف السياسيه فتبادلت الطرفان
الاتهامات بالمسؤوليه عن الانتهاكات
الحقوقيه فقد اتهم الجيش قوات الدعم
السريع بوضع اسلحه ثقيله في شوارع الاحياء
السكنيه كما اتهمها باستعمال المواطنين
نكرها ورفض السماح لهم بالخروج لاطول فتره
ممكنه واتهم الجيش القوات كذلك بمهاجمه
دبلوماسيين اجانب في الع الخرطوم اما قوات
الدعم السريع فاكدت ان الاجانب ضيوف وخط
احمر يمنع تجاوزه واعلن التخوفها مما قالت
انه تضارب في تصريحات الجيش بشان الهدنه
محذره من تعدد مراكز القرار في الجيش
وتعود هيئه انسانيه محليه ودوليه على هذه
النافذه الزمنيه للهدنه لايصال المساعدات
الى محتاجها وكشف حقيقه تاثير المواجهات
المسلحه على المدنيين الذين غابت اخبارهم
خلف دخان المعارك
هذا واظهرت صور ملتقطه عبر اقمار الصناعيه
اثار القتال المستمر بين قوات الدعم
السريع والجيش السوداني وتظهر الصور التي
التقطت صباح اليوم اضرارا لاحقت بطائرات
مقاتله ومروحيات عسكريه في عده قواعد
عسكريه منها قاعده مروي بالولايه الشماليه
كما تظهر ايضا تضرر مروحيات عسكريه في
قاعده جبل اولياء جنوبيه الخرطوم ودمارا
لاحق بطائرات مقاتله في قاعده العبيد
الجويه جنوب غربي الخرطوم
ينظر الى من الخرطوم احمد يحيى الباحث
والمحلل السياسي ومن الخرطوم ايضا اللواء
محمد عجيب مدير الاعلام العسكري الاسبق في
السادسه من مساء الغد لواء محمد عجيب
ستنتهي هذه الهدنه الانسانيه التي بدات في
السادسه مساء اليوم هل هنالك اي تصور لما
سيجري بعد السادسه مساء من يوم غد
لواء محمد عجيب
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته عليكم
السلام هل سمعت السؤال تحيه لك وتحيه لكل
المشاهدين قناه الجزيره تقربت ممكن تعيد
السؤال سؤالي ان الهدنه ستنتهي غدا
السادسه مساء هل هنالك تصور سواء لدى
الجيش او لدى الدعم السريع لما سيجري بعد
انتهاء هذه الهدنه الانسانيه يوم غد في
الثالثه مساء
هذه الهدنه اعلن عنها اليوم ببساطه من
الامم الامم المتحده ولكن حسب المعلومات
المتوفره الان
القوات المسلحه كان لديها تحفظات على هذه
الهدنه بمعنى عدم التزام الطرف الاخر
الشريحه عدم التزامها
من الموضوع العسكري لا تعني مجرد وقف
اطلاق نار وانما تعني ايضا الوقف كل
التحركات والتشوين
من ضمن الاعداد الاستماع في القطار الان
على الارض
الخرطوم نسمع اصوات
الطلقات ودويه الرصاص في اكثر من موقع مما
يعني ان الهدنه الان عمليه ربما لا تكون
سالك المفعول ولكن بشكل او باخر تم
الالتزام بهذه الامه فيما تبقى من هذا
الليل وصباح الغد
فسيحقبها ايضا نفس الواقع باعتبار ان
الهدنه اصلا لاغراض العمل الانساني
ولاغراض تسيير الامر في المرافق
الاستراتيجيه في الخدمات مثل المياه
والكهرباء والمستشفيات ومن ذلك ايضا ربما
تكون هذه الهدنه ذات طابع انساني اكثر من
كونها ذات طابع عسكري لان القوات المسلحه
الان حسب تصريحات من مسؤولين وقادف الجيش
لا تقبل اي وساطات فيما يتعلق بتفاوض او
حوار مع قوات التمرد وتع يد التوصيف
القانوني العسكري اللي ما قام ان يقلد
الدعم السريع بانه مجرد
عسكري لا يمكن التفاوض معه في في اصل
الدائره ولكن يمكن السماح بفتره
اطلاق النار لاغراض الاعمال الانساني
وبالتالي لا تظن ان الجيش مستعد لتمديد
هذه الهدنه لما بعد الثالثه من مساء الغد
لا اتوقع لا لا اتوقع لا اتوقع الجيش
سيسمح بتمديد هذه الهدنه لانها تعني انها
تتيح لقوات التمرد التقاط انفاسها واعاده
ترتيبها وتنظيم صفوفها وربما تتوقع حسب
تصريحات من العسكري مسؤولين امداد يصلها
من بعض
المناطق التي او بعض الدول التي تساند هذا
التمرد وتمضيه بان يواصل في هذا العمل
ولذلك هذه اسباب منطقيه وواقعيه تجعل
القوات المسلحه ترفض
الهدنه
اشتراطاتها الانسانيه ويتحول الى تفاوض
وايضا
بما انها هدنه انسانيه
حتى حتى هذه اللحظه حسب مراسلينا لم يتحرك
لم يتغير اي شيء في الوضع الانساني ما هو
تصور الجيش
لتحسين الوضع الانساني في الساعات القليله
المتبقيه كيف كيف سيحدث ذلك
للاسف كما ذكرت لك قبل قليل
بان هذه الهدنه المفعول الامن حتى الان
نسمع اصوات طلقات الرصاص والغزائف في
مناطق مختلفه ومتفرقه من الخرطوم اتوقع ان
يعمل الجيش على دعم العمل الانساني في
المستشفيات وفي خدمات المياه والكهرباء
واعلن الجيش صراحه عن ذلك ان السلاح
المهندسين يرافق تقوم من الفنيين المختصين
في المياه والكهرباء ويسعى معهم لاعاده
هذه الخدمات هذه هي الجهود التي تقوم بها
القوات المسلحه في المجال الانساني حتى
قبل الاعلان عن هذه الاذن وستستمر هذه
الجهود اثناء هذه الهدنه ان قدر لها ان
ترى النور ولكن على الارض الان واقع مختلف
ابقوا معنا اللواء محمد عجيب احمد يحيى
الباحث والمحل السياسي من الخرطوم هذه
التحركات التي يقوم بها الجيش ضمن مهامه
لحفظ الامن
وممارسه السياده لانه هو جيش الدوله في
النهايه كيف تنظر اليها هل ينبغي ان تنظر
اليها الدعم السريع على انها انتهاك
للهدنه
هو طبعا مؤكد اذا كان التحرك في اطار
العمل الانساني لا يعتبر انتحاك للفتنه
باعتبار ان الاليات الانسانيه
والادوات في العمل تختلف من الاليات التي
تستخدم في العمل العسكريه بالتالي مؤشرات
التحرك وادوات التحرك ووسائل التحرك هي من
يعني تكون هي الحقبه وتحدد شكل التحرك
وبالتالي هذا ما قد يجعل قوات الدعم
السريع تحدد ان هذا التهرب هو تحرك عسكري
او غيره
ان هذه الهدنه يجب فعلا ان تقول هدنه
انسانيه لانه هناك مشاكل كبيره في
المستشفيات ومشاكل كبيره في الحركه
الاجتماعيه لان هذه الحرب كانت عباره عن
مفاجاه لكثير من المواطنين وعطلت كثير من
الحركه باعتبار انها حركه متفاجئه طلاب في
الجامعات الرجوع الى المستشفيات ولم
يستطيع الرجوع حركه اجتماعيه تعطلت بسبب
يعني ليست بالحركه الطبيعيه لكن شخص
يرجع الى منزله ولم يستطيع في اطار تدابير
العيد وترتيباته كثيرين الى الاسواق وسبب
هذه الحرب يعني اشكالات لانه يتواصل مع
اسرته بصوره اخرى فبالتالي انا اعتقد يجب
ان يشتغل هذا الامر
الواقع في المواطنين
كل شخص يرجع الى مكانه طبيعي ويحصل معالجه
للقضايا
هل يمكن ان تعمل هذه الهدنه دون ان تلتزم
ايضا قوات الدعم السريع بعدم تحريك لا قطع
عسكريه ولا تشكيلات عسكريه
يبدو اننا فقدنا الاتصال بالاستاذ احمد
يحيى الباحث هو المحلل السياسي
نعود الى اللواء محمد عجيب مره اخرى ايضا
فيما يتعلق بتحركات الدعم السريع اذا لم
تكن تحركات ذات صبغه عسكريه متعلقه
بمجريات المعركه الان هل يمكن ان ينظر
اليها الجيش على انها انتهاك لهذه الهدنه
قطعا لا اذا كانت تحركات قوه الدعم السريع
داخل نطاق العمل الانساني فهذا هو الهدف
الاول من هذه الهدنه
وستنظر اليها القوات المسلحه بتقضيه ان
هذا واحد من الاسباب لانه في النهايه
هؤلاء مواطنين
حق المواطنه
الانسان
في العلاج وفي الطعام وفي الحركه وما الى
ذلك
الدعم السريع بان تكون كل التحركات
والاعمال التي تقوم بها خلال هذه الفتره
هي اعمال لغرض العمل الانساني فهذا سيجد
الاحترام والتقدير والقوات المسلحه وهذا
هو الاسف الهدف الاساسي من هذه الهدنه بل
ان القوات المسلحه تذهب ابعد من ذلك
باعتبار ان الهدف الانساني ومطلوبات للعمل
الانساني هي واحده من المنهجيه التي
والاحترازات التي تضع القوات المسلحه
باعتبار اثناء تنفيذه كثير من الاعمال
العسكريه بل ان هذه الاعتباط الانسانيه هي
ربما تكون في بعض الاحيان تعيق طبيعه
العمل العسكري والقوات المسلحه لا ترفض
هذا الامر بل يتقيد به ولذلك اي عمل
انساني يلقى القبول والاحترام
في اطار العمل الانساني يمكن قبولها من
قبل الجيش احمد يحيى عاد الينا الباحث
والمحلل السياسي وانت قلت نفس الشيء عن
تحركات الجيش فيما يتعلق بالمجال الانساني
اذا ما الذي يعيق
وهنا سؤالي لاحمد يحيى ما الذي يعيق العمل
الانسان الان يعني حتى الان لم يحدث شيء
لم يتغير شيء
بطرفين في المعركه باعتبار ان هاجمه هي
يجب ان تكون في حقيقيه للعمل الانساني حرف
فرص
للمؤسسات والمنظمات الانسانيه الطبيه
والمؤسسات التي تعمل في مجال العمل
الانساني والخدمي
في المياه والذي تعمل في المجال الغذائي
والكهربائي والصحي
المسائل العمل الانساني بصوره عامه لكن
عدم الثقه بين الطرفين تجعل هذه المؤسسات
ايضا هي لا تثق في في هذه الهدنه بصوره
كامله بل انما المواطنين يترقبون وينظرون
والكل الان يسهل هناك طلقات ناريه هنا
وهناك نسمع زويا الانفجارتنا هناك نوعا ما
ولا نعرف اي مصدرها بالتالي تجعل
المواطنين حذرين في التعامل مع هذه الهدنه
لكن في تقدير الساعات القادمه حتى الصباح
سوف تنجري الامور بصوره واضحه وتكون واضحه
واذا فعلا التزم الطرفان بهذه الهدنه انا
اعتقد هذا نجاح
الى انه برضو يجب ان تكون هناك خلاص صحيح
هناك حرب والحرب له الياته ولو تدابيره
وله العسكريه
هو الخطط الاستراتيجيه في الهجوم وفي غيره
لكن في النهايه الان رده واحده وابنا
افتكر انه ايضا
على الوطنيين الحاذبين على مصلحه السودان
من القوه المجتمعيه التاريخيه التي هي
يمكن ان تجد اذن صاغيه من الطرفين وعلى
القوه السياسيه السودانيه يمكن ان تعمل
الاجراء بعض الاتصالات باعتبار ان هناك
فرصه يمكن ان يفتح لهم بشكل عام الحركه
حواريه واذا ما تم يعني استلام كل هذه
الامور وذهبت الى امام اعتقد يمكن ان تكون
هناك اختراقات لان هذه حرف فيتكلم تكلف
الشعب السوداني كثيرا
وتكلفه خاصه ان الشعب السوداني الان
ينتظر ان يعيش وضع افضل بعد مجموعه
الاجراءات التي تمت من خلال
اتفاقيات السلامه التي اورون سابقا ومن
خلال التغيير الذي تم في 2019 وما قبله
السودان عانى كثيرا من المشكلات ومن
الاحترام ومن النزاعات
بالتالي عان الاموال لكثير من السودانيين
ان ينطلقوا نحو بناء الدوله ووضع اللبنات
الاساسيه في اداره السودان بصوره امثل
والخروج من هذه الادمات بصوره
نريد ان يؤول الاوان او ان يان الاوان
يهون الاوان الى لانهاء الحرب اولا قبل
الدخول في هذه ربما كثير من الاستديو
يريدون ذلك الان ان يعودوا الى بيوتهم
الذين لم يستطيعوا العوده الى بيوتهم لكن
نشكرك احمد يحيى من الخرطوم ولواء محمد
عجيب من الخرطوم ايضا شكرا جزيلا لكم احمد
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
هذه الحرب لها ضريبه انسانيه تحذر منظمات
انسانيه محليه دوليه من كارثه انسانيه
تهدد السودان ومرافقه الصحيه بسبب استمرار
القتالي بين الفرقاء في شوارع الخرطوم
ومناطق اخرى من البلاد وقد حث مدير منظمه
الصحه العالميه جميع الاطراف المتنحره على
السماح بالوصول غير المقيد الى المستشفيات
اما اللجنه التمهيديه لنقابه الاطباء
السودانيين فقد حذرت من خروج 16 مستشفى عن
الخدمه بسبب الوضع الامني المتدهور
والافتقار الى الامكانيات الطبيه اللازمه
كم من نداء عاجل واستغاثه من مستشفيات
السودان سيسمع صداهما وسط عزيز الرصاص وكم
من ماساه انسانيه لم توثقها الكاميرا في
هذا البلد منذ حوله لاقتتال الى ساحه حرب
مفتوحه على الاسواق يجلى مرضى الكلى في
مركز السلمى واستفاوض السلاح لدخوله ولا
خروج امنين منذ السبت الدامى ولا طواقيمه
طبيه تعمل في ظروف طبيعيه لا يستثني سلاح
الفرقاء جو وارضا المرافق الصحيه التي
كانت في زمن السلام الهاش تفتقر الى
الكثير من احتياجاتها الاساسيه القطاع
الصحي في السودان وخاصه في المناطق التي
تشهد اشتباكات عنيفه بين طرفي الصراع على
وشك الانهيار ان لم يكن الانهياره قد بدا
فعلا
اكدت اللجنه التمهيديه لنقابه الاطباء
السودانيين خروج 16 مستشفى عن الخدمه
وتعرض بعضها للقصف في الخرطوم اغلقت تسعه
مستشفيات ابوابها بسبب انقطاع الكهرباء
والمياه والنقص الحاد في الكوادر الطبيه
ووقود المولدات ثلاثه مستشفيات في الخرطوم
بحري لم تعد قادره على تقديم الخدمات
للمرضى والجرحى لافتقارها للمستلزمات
الطبيه الضروريه في الابيض التي تعاني
اصلا من قله المرافق الصحيه اعلن مستشفى
الضمان التخصصي خارج الخدمه عندما يغلق
مستشفيان فيراوي فذلك بمثابه الكارثه
لسكان هذه المنطقه
ما بقي من مرافق صحيه مفتوحه مهدد
بالاغلاق في اي لحظه فهي تعمل بالحد
الادنى من الامكانيات والحد الاقصى من
انعدام الامن خارجها وبالقرب منها تقف
المنظمه الدوليه تعاجزه عن اداء مهامها
امام مشهد درامي يزداد قتامه وتعقيدا مع
كل ساعه اقتتال في الخرطوم وغيرها من
المناطق
الوضع يقترب من ان يكون ميؤوسا منه
اولويتنا الان هي ان نصل للمستشفيات التي
تنقصها المياه والكهرباء وبدات الامدادات
الطبيه في النفاذ
هل من مجيب لدعوه مدير منظمه الصحه
العالميه لطرفي الصراع من اجل اتاحه
امكانيه الوصول غير المقيد الى المرافق
الطبيه لجميع المحتاجين الى الرعايه
لا احد يمكنه ضمان ذلك لا يعرف من يسيطر
على من وعلى ماذا في مشهد الثابت فيه صوت
الانفجارات ورائحه البارود وسط شكوك
بفشلها حتى قبل ان تبدا دخلت الهدنه
الانسانيه التي وعد بها المتنحران على صوت
الاشتباكات والخروقات قبل بها تحت الضغط
الامريكي يفترض ان تكون مدتها 24 ساعه في
ساعه شبه الهدوء القليله يفر سكان بعض
احياء الخرطوم الى مناطق بعيده عن نيران
الاشتباكات على الاقل حتى الان لا ضمان ان
نيران حرب الزعامات لن تحرق ولايه اخرى في
بلد لم يعرف الاستقرار التام منذ عقود وهو
الان فحيه السيناريو الاسوا والاكثر دمويه
والاكثر صدمه ومفاجاه للسودانيين لكن
ينضموا الينا من القاهره الدكتور احمد
المنظري المدير الاقليميه لمنظمه الصحه
العالميه دكتور احمد المنظري الاميد العام
للامم المتحده قال ان الوضع في السودان
بالفعل قبل اندلاع هذه المواجهه كان حرجا
والان اصبح كارثيا كيف تقيمون انتم في
منظمه الصحه العالميه الوضع الصحي الان
بعد خروج سته عشره سته عشره مستشفى او سته
عشره مستشفى عن الخدمه في السودان
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم شكرا جزيلا اخي
زين العابدين على الاستضافه وكل عام وانتم
بخير طبعا كما تفضلتم في التقرير وكما
ذكرت يعني الوضع وضع النظام الصحي في
السودان سابقا يعني منذ سنوات وضع يعني
ضعيف جدا هش جدا يعاني من الكثير من
التحديات نقص في الكادر الطبي نقص في
المعدات والاجهزه نقص في الموارد الاخرى
اتت هذه النزاعات المسلحه بين الفريقين
للاسف واكملت على الباقي حاليا كما ذكرتم
في التقرير يوجد حوالي 16 مستشفى
خارج عن الخدمه بسبب الهجوم المباشر على
هذه المؤسسات
عدد كذلك ما يقارب من 16 مستشفى في عموم
السودان تعاني من نقص في الموظفين
وبالتالي احتماليه الاغلاق هناك نقص كذلك
في يعني سيارات الاسعاف بسبب الهجمات تم
الاستيلاء على عدد منها للاسف من قبل
الفرق المتنازعه هناك عدم مقدرا للعاملين
الصحيين الذهاب الى تلك المستشفيات وتقديم
الخدمات اللازمه هناك صعوبه وتحدي كبير
لنقل المصابين والجرحى وكذلك المتوفين الى
تلك المستشفيات لتقديم العنايه اللازمه
للجميع
ما الذي يمكن عمله
والله نحن كمنظمه صحه عالميه يعني تحركات
الفرق منذ اللحظه الاولى التي يعني بدا
فيها هذا النزاع لدينا مكتب قطري وهناك
فرق متخصصه فنيه قامت بتقييم الوضع
بالتعاون مع السلطات الصحيه من حيث ترصد
واحصائيات الحالات المصابه وكذلك التعرف
على الوضع الصحي في عموم المناطق التي
تعرضت لهذه النزاعات قمنا بتنسيق يعني
لدينا مخازن في السودان فيها مستلزمات
طبيه قمنا بتسليمها الى المؤسسات الصحيه
ولكن للاسف هذه قاربت على النفاف لدينا
مخزن المنظمه اللوجستي في دبي يتم الان
يعني التنسيق لايصال هذه المساعدات ولكن
للاسف كما علمتم يعني جميع المداخل سواء
البريه او الجويه او البحريه مغلقه ولكن
نقوم بالتنسيق
بنقل هذه المساعدات والمؤن الطبيه
من خلال البحر الاحمر وميناء بورسودان
التحدي كبير اخي زين العابدين وهنا اناشد
جميع الفرقاء في السودان بتغليب مصلحه
السودان ووطنهم السودان واهل السودان
والانسانيه كما يناشر به الجميع وبالتالي
يعني انقاذ الارواح حتى الان يعني تم
تسجيل ما يقارب من 250 وفاه جرى هذه
النزاعات واكيد العدد اكبر تم تسجيل ما
يقارب 2500 اصابه تتراوح بعض منها اصابات
بالغه وصعوبه تقديم الخدمات اللازمه لها
فهو تحدي كبير الان صوت العقل لازم يغلب
على الفرقاء ويجب ان يعود لصوت الحكمه غير
ذلك الخسائر ستكون فادحه وهم من يتحملوا
هذه المسؤوليه وليس يعني اي شخص اخر سواء
داخل السودان او خارجها المشكله الان هذه
المستشفيات تخرج عن الخدمه تباعا لانه لم
يعد لديها امدادات لا تستطيع ان تفعل شيئا
هنالك مشكله وصول ثم هنالك ايضا مشكله
امدادات مشكله وصول الى المستشفى ومشكله
وصولات الى المستشفى هل لديكم حل يعني
مخازنكم الموجوده في
السودان مثلا هل يمكن ان تساعد هل هي فتحت
لهذه المستشفيات هل هنالك تنسيق مع الفرق
الطبيه مع وزاره الصحه او المسؤولين
المدنيين
نعم نعم هناك تنسيق مباشر جدا يعني مع
السلطات المختصه في عموم السودان من اجل
تحريك الموارد والمستلزمات الطبيه
الموجوده في مخازننا في السودان ولكن كما
تفضلت هي قاربت على النفاذ صعوبه الوصول
الى السودان هو تحدي كبير طبعا التحدي
الاخر كما تفضلت هنا هناك نقص في امدادات
الكهرباء هناك نقص في امدادات المياه نقص
في امدادات الدم على سبيل المثال ومشتقات
الدم للجرحى والمصابين
يعني يؤثر على تقديم الخدمات الصحيه
وبالتالي كما تفضلت احتماليه اغلاق عدد
كبير منها وخروج عن الخدمه ليس بسبب
الهجمات فقط وانما بسبب النقص والتمويل
وصعوبه الحصول على الموظفين ووصولهم الى
تلك المؤسسات الصحيه اشكرك شكرا جزيلا من
القاهره احمد المنظري الدكتور احمد
المنظري المدير الاقليمي لمنظمه الصحه
العالميه شكرا جزيلا دكتور
الاتحاد الافريقي ومنظمه ايجاد ينخرطان في
اتصالات المكثفه بين الجانبين نظرا للقبول
الذي تتمتع به الاطراف الافريقيه لدى جميع
المكونات السياسيه والعسكريه في السودان
وتستمر الولايات المتحده ايضا ضمن
الرباعيه الخاصه بالسودان في اتصالاتها في
محاوله لتهدئه الاوضاع تفاصيل الاتصالات
الافريقيه والغربيه في الازمه السودانيه
نتابعها في هذا التقرير
بالتجربه فان ترتيب البيت السوداني خصوصا
بعد اسقاط نظام البشير جعل من الاتحاد
الافريقي عاملا مؤثرا في تشكيل المرحله
الانتقاليه والمشهد السياسي
ومع خروج الامور اليوم عن السيطره
والاقتتال بين رفاق السلاح فان الامل تعلق
على جهوده مجددا يحظى الطرف الافريقي
بقبول بين جميع المكونات السياسيه
والعسكريه في السودان وقد يكون من
المؤهلين للتواصل لحل للازمه لم ترق جهود
الوساطه بعد الى بلوره مبادره واضحه
المعالم لكنها قد تكون في طور التشكل
وساطه بدات منذ اليوم الاول للقتال ويتوقع
ان يتوجه مفوض الاتحاد مستفكي وفريق من
مجلس السلم والامن الافريقي للخرطوم
تتركز جهود الاتحاد حاليا على الالتزام
بالهدنه الانسانيه علها تكون مقدمه لاحداث
خرق يتيح اتفاقا بين الطرفين وقد عطلت
الاشتباكات العنيفه قرب مطار الخرطوم وصول
الوفد بينما تؤكد مفوضيه الاتحاد الافريقي
ان هناك محاولات مستمره لوصول مسؤولين
افارقه الى الخرطوم الهيئه الحكوميه
للتنميه لدول شرق افريقيا ايجاد قررت
بدورها بعد اجتماع طارئ افاده ثلاثه رؤساء
للخرطوم بهدف الوساطه رئيس جنوب السودان
والرئيس الجيبوتي والرئيس الكيني لايجاد
تاريخ مع السياسه في السودان سبق لها ان
دخلت وسيطا عام 93 مع متمردي جنوب السودان
انذاك
الى جانب الجهود الافريقيه قد يكون
الطرفان الغربيان في الرباعيه الخاصه
بالسودان اي الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا
من اكثر الدول التي تمارس ضغوطا لتهدئه
الاقتتال وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه انتون
بلينكن عقد اجتماعا مع نظيره البريطاني
ليؤكد الرجلان بعدها على ضروره استعاده
مسار الانتقال الديمقراطي في البلاد
لا مبادره واضحه حتى الان لكن قد تكون
ضغوط لندن الاكثر نجاحا فالولايات المتحده
استثمرت بالفعل في العمليه السياسيه في
السودان بعد الاطاحه بالبشير ويقول
مراقبون انها لن تسمح بانهيار مسار التحول
بشكل مفاجئ اسرائيل دخلت على خط الاتصالات
بين الطرفين بحسب وزير خارجيتها اليكوهن
تقول انها تحاول القيام بما يمكنها لتهدئه
الامور خصوصا انها بذلت في الاونه الاخيره
جهودا لجذب السوداني نحو التطفئه
دوليه ايضا دعا وزراء وخارجيه الدول
لمجموعه السبع طرفي النزاعي في السودان
الى وقف الاعمال العدائيه فورا والعوده
الى طاوله المفاوضات في بيان صدر بعد
يومين من المحادثات التي اجراها في
اليابان حتى وزراء خارجيه الدول السبع
الطرفين النزاع على وقف الاعمال العدائيه
دون شروط مسبقه كما دعى وزراء وخارجيه دول
السبعه الى نبذ العنف والعوده للمفاوضات
واتخاذ خطوات فعاله لخفض التوترات وضمان
سلامه جميع المدنيين والدبلوماسيين
والعاملين في المجال الانساني
تنضم الينا من مشجن السفيره سوزان بيج
نائبه نائبته سعد وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
الشؤون الافريقيه السابقا والمستشاره
السابقه للمبعوث الخاص للسودان وجنوب
السودان سيدي سوزان اهلا بك اذا الجهود
الامريكيه والدوليه اسفرت عن هدنه لمده 24
ساعه هل يمكن فعل المزيد
في الحقيقه اعتقد اننا بحاجه للقيام
بالمزيد ولكن الصعبه هو اننا لم نستخدم
التاثير او ربما المصطلح الملائم ليس
تاثير لم نستخدم ربما الادوات التي يمكن
ان او كان يمكن ان استخدمها قبل حصولي ما
حصل ولا سيما التوجه الى العسكر والى
المليشيات وترك المدنيين
الذين كانوا قتاهموا في الاطاحه بالبشير
اعتقد ان الوقت حان لكي نتفاعل مع
المدنيين وكان يجب التعامل معهم والتفاعل
معهم منذ البدايه ولكن الفرصه لا تزال
سانحه هل لهذا هل كان لهذا ان يلغي دور
المسلحين سواء كانوا من الجيش او من الدعم
السريع هم من لديهم الطائرات هو الدبابات
والمدافع هل هل يعني احتضان المدنيين
وحدهم كان كافيا في رايك
لا انا اعتقد انهم بحاجه الى احتضان
العنصر المدني ايضا
برايي ان جزءا من هذا الخطا الذي ارتكب هو
فقط التعامل مع
العسكر والميليشات
بحيث ان مجلس السياده كان سوف او وصل الى
مرحله كان سوف يقاد من قبل مدنيين ومنذ
سنتين حمايه والبرهان قام بانقلاب ضده
وتبقى من الحكومه ولم يحصل شيء
حتى انا صفقنا لهم كما لو ان شيئا لم يحصل
اذا كان خطا ولكن دائما هناك طريقه
لمعالجه الخطا حتى بطريقه متاخره ولكن
العنصر المدني قد تم التخلي عنه هو الذي
قاد هذه الجهود التي الت الى التغيير
يمكن تدارك هذا الخطا كيف كيف يمكن تدارك
اذا كان ما حدث من الولايات المتحده كان
خطا
كيف يمكن تدارك هذا الخطا ما هي الادوات
المتبقيه الان في يد الولايات المتحده وقد
اندلع الصراع بالفعل
انه لا تعتقد ان
او انا ارى دبلوماسيه هي عمل يجري على قدم
وساق انا لست في الداخل ولم اعد اعمل مع
الحكومه الامريكيه لست مطلع على كافه
تفاصيل ولكن اعرفه انه دائما يجب ان
اتفاعل مع العنصر العسكري هم الذين
يمتلكون السلاح ولكن من المهم جدا ايضا ان
نجري حوارا مستمرا مع الاطراف التي فعلا
تريد ان تشهد تغييرا ديمقراطيا في البلاد
وانا اتحدث بالنسبه الى المدنيين في
السودان اعتبروا انه لا دوره للعسكر في
السياسه وهذا ما لم يحصل اذا بحسب ما
ارى الامور
فان نقابات الاطباء والعمال وقوات الحريه
او قوى الحريه والتغيير قد اصدرت جميعها
تصريحات
وقالت انها لم يتم اشراكها في المفاوضات
في السابق
هي غير موجوده الان لان النزاع يحصل ولكن
اعتقد في المستقبل
هذه المجموعات المدنيه بحاجه للتواجد على
طاوله المفاوضات يجب ان تكون هذا العمليه
شامله قدر الامكان ولا تنحصر بالعنصر
العسكري وشب العسكري
اساسا لكن ماذا عن حلفاء الولايات المتحده
المنخرطين في السودان تقريبا معظم حلفاء
الولايات المتحده المنخرطين في السودان لا
يريدون ديمقراطيه في السودان
ولكن اذا كنا فعلا نقول اننا ندعم
ديمقراطيه
واننا ندعم اراده الشعب ورغبات الشعر وهذا
ما كانت تصرح بها الولايات المتحده ويصرح
به شركائها ايضا طبعا لكل دوله مصالحها
ولكنني اعتقد انه من
مصلحه الولاده المتحده بكل تاكيد
ان تحاول مساعده الشعاب والناس المدنيين
على تحقيق اهدافهم وغاياتهم الا وهي
الديمقراطيه وانهاء هذا الحكم العسكري
القاسي الذي طال تحت حكم البشير شكرا
جزيلا لك من
السفيره سوزان بيج نائبته مساعد وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه للشؤون الافريقيه
السابقا والمستشاره السابقه ايضا للمبعوث
الامريكي الخاص للسودان وجنوب السودان
اذا المجتمع الدولي يراقب ما يجري بكثير
من القلق والترقب فموقع السودان
الاستراتيجي ومكانته الاقليميه يجعلاني
اطرافا كثيره تخشى من استمرار الصراع
وتاثيره اقليميا ودوليا كما في تقرير احمد
فالوالدين
يلعلع الرصاص على ضفاف النيل لم يدخل
المجتمع الدولي وعباراته للتحذير مما يجري
لا فائده
اللجوء الى العنف فما يحدث في ثالث اضخم
دوله افريقيه يهم الجميع فمنذ بدا القتال
وشرت اتصالات حديثه بكافه الاطراف من
السعوديه وقطر والامارات والاتحاد
الافريقي سعيا للتهدئه يتراشق العسكر على
ارض السودان بالرصاص والكلمات وما يخشاه
المجتمع الدولي هو تطاير الشرر الى ابعد
من ذلك بسبب الموقع الاستراتيجي للسودان
فلو استمر الصراع دون حسم قد يتصل الخط
الناري بين البحر الاحمر وتخوم المحيط
ليتشكل خط هشحون بالاضطرابات يعيش السودان
في منطقه معسكره اصلا فجنوب السودان متوتر
واثيوبيا خارجه توا من حرب مصر تقول انها
ترقب تطورات في السودان عن كثب فتداخل
البعد الجغرافي بميراث العلاقات والتحولات
والحسابات تجعل المخاوف مما الات الوضع
السوداني بندا امنيا وسياسيا اساسيا لدى
القاهره
ما يجري في السودان يهم القوه الكبرى كذلك
فاليروسيا حضورها في اطار الاهتمام
بالساحه الافريقيه سواء بعلاقاتها
وبمصالحها وبخطط ابرزها القاعده البحريه
الروسيه في بورت سودان فضلا عن تقارير
تتحدث عن وجود لقوات فاجنر للصين ايضا
وجودها في الساحه السودانيه وهي القوه
الضخمه الباحثه عن مجالات نفوذ جديده اما
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه فولت قريبه من
التحولات المتسارعه منذ سقوط نظام عمر
البشير وكانت لها مطالب كتفعيل المسار
السياسي وضمان الحكم المدني وخروج الجيش
من الحكم حسب المعلن من سياساتها
[موسيقى]
كل هذا يجعل الجنرالين المتصارعين امام
لحظه فارقه لا يقتصر زخمها على الداخل
السوداني بل هي لحظه تقاطع اسئله ومواقف
ومصالح دوليه تاخذ بعين الاعتبار مكانه
السودان في الجغرافيا وفي السياسه
في اخبارنا الاخرى اعرب ستيفان دو جاريك
المتحدث باسم امين العام للامم المتحده عن
قلق المنظمه الدوليه البالغ من اعتقال
الرئيس حركه النهضه راشد الغنوشي واكد
دوجاريك اهميه التمسك الحكومه والرئيس
التونسي بالسياده القانون
في المجتمع المدني واقتحام مكتب حزب
النهضه من المهم للغايه للحكومه التونسيه
والرئيس التونسي التمسك بسياده القانون
بما في ذلك الحق في محاكمه عادله والحقوق
المدنيه والسياسيه الدوليه التي تعد وتونس
صرفا فيها وكذلك يطلقه سراحه جميع الاشخاص
الذين اعتقلوا بشكل تعسفي بمن فيهم الذين
اعتقلوه لمجرد ممارستهم لحريتهم في
التعبير او حريه التجمع
كان المتحدث باسم الحرس الوطني في تونس قد
اعلن ايقاف خمسه اشخاص على ذمه التحقيقات
بينهم راشد الغنوشي وقال المتحدث باسم
الحرس الوطني لفرقه مكافحه جرائم
تكنولوجيا المعلومات تعهدت بالتحقيق في
تصريحات رئيس حركه النهضه اضاف ان هذه
التصريحات تندرج ضمن افعال مجرمه المقصود
منها تبديل هيئه الدوله او حمل السكان على
مهاجمه بعضهم واوضح المتحدث باسم الحرس
الوطني ان النيابه العامه اذنت بوضع مقر
حزب النهضه على ذمه الفرقه الخامسه
لتفتيشه
هذا ونقلت وكاله الانباء الفرنسيه عن حركه
النهضه التونسيه ان قوات الامن اغلقت مقر
الحركه هذا وقالتلز ان السلطات التونسيه
منعت الاجتماعات في جميع مقر النهضه
واغلقت المقر الرئيسيه ايضا لجبهه الخلاص
المعارضه
اما الرئيس التونسي قيس سعيد فقال ان تونس
تخوض حرب تحرير وطني لفرد سيارتها الكامله
واكد في كلمه خلال احياء عيد قوات الامن
ضروره ان يلعب القضاء دوره في هذه المرحله
وواجبون المقدس
خاصه في هذه المرحله التي تعيشها بلا دره
والحفاظ على الدوله ومؤسساتها
وعلى المجتمع وكيانه
اننا
نخوض اليوم
مان على نفس جبهه القتال
حربه تحرير وطني
وانني على يقين
بانكم تشعرون
بنفس الشعور
المثقل بالمسؤوليه
التقى وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل
بن فرحان الذي ادى زياره رسميه الى سوريا
التقى بالرئيس السوري بشار الاسد واوردت
وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه انه تمت مناقشه
الجهود المبذوله للتوصل الى حل سياسي
للازمه السوريه يحافظ على وحده سوريا
وهويتها العربيه وسلامه يا رضيع كما بحث
الجانبان الخطوات